[Music]
jonathan is in denver hey jonathan
welcome to the ramsey show
hey mr ramsey george uh nice talking to
you guys you too how can we help
um so me and my girlfriend have been
dating for around eight months now um i
have
introduced her to you guys plan
um i'm trying to find the best way to
help her
without being an enabler or any sort of
uh
you know back end where she ends up just
relying on me um she does
she doesn't appreciate when i do like
ask her if she would like some money in
the
there's a couple weeks where
she would dig down on me because uh she
would um
she would uh
end up
just saying that she's broke or like she
just can't
find a way out so i'm just trying to
find the best way to help her without
being an enabler
so she's actively asking you for money
regularly
no uh she she never does it's more like
i i to ask her if she would like some
money just because i don't like seeing
her struggle and she's offended by that
um i wouldn't say she's offended she
doesn't take any sort of like offense to
it any offensive stance um she's very
understanding she's very caring um okay
so what's her problem how much debt does
she have
um i am unsure um she won't disclose
that to me i said we're still dating
it's not like we're married or anything
like that
but i do see her as a potential
sh i do see as me and her getting
married because uh she's not until you
find out what the flip's going on
yeah
um i mean
she's currently in school
there is times where uh she is a cna so
she gets put on call at times um i have
you know informed you're like hey you
know can you try looking at other
departments in your hospital to see if
you could get you know any extra income
or anything like that but i just feel
like sometimes
um she tries over here
i'm 24. how old is she
uh she's 24 as well okay
all right um so here's the thing
in your mind this relationship has
progressed further than it has in hers
um
you are you are completely dabbling in
her business and she doesn't want you to
know what it is
correct
you are further along the path than she
is
i do feel like in terms of emotion um
it is mutual
because you're willing to tell her
everything about you and about your
money and she's not willing to tell you
what's going on with her money
correct and that may be coming from
shame and some baggage but we have to
unpack this before this relationship
progresses any further
correct yeah this is a blockade to um
to you all getting to know each other
better
at a deep level called intimacy
okay
and so emotional intimacy and so you
guys getting to know each other and
disclosing and starting to share life
is a precursor
to you guys going to an into an
engagement
and so until she's ready to take that
next step you're standing over here
ready to go step she's not ready to go
um and so i guess you just got to find
out a is this shame or b is she just not
ready
to move forward as much as you're ready
to move forward there's pos either one's
possible
i do feel it's more in the shame part
just because there is points where you
know
she is hard on money and she still tries
to find a way to budget and make herself
make her enemies you don't have any idea
what's going on
because you don't know how much she has
in debt you don't know how much income
she has you don't know what's going on
all you saw is your girlfriend crying
that's all you know
yeah i mean i do know what she makes um
she has uh disclosed some information in
terms of like what she makes um what
she's trying to do but in terms of like
um her
trying to hear her debt her student
loans and stuff um i've asked her and
it's more like i feel like she's ashamed
well i mean
you can't go forward in this
relationship until she can get past this
it's a blockade and so you got to just
back up and give this some more time or
it's a cup it's a cut bait thing one of
the two i don't know which it is but it
doesn't sound like it's that yet but um
at some point we have to be able to open
up about these things in spite of shame
in spite of pride whatever it is
this is the ramsay show